the damage  that the mainstream media and fauci and  the cdc and the nih the damage that they  have done to young people the  psychological damage  of making everyone afraid of everything  that that none of this can go away till  we have zero covid it is real reinstate  reinstate  reinstate  when i saw this video i was like this  can't be real and yet it is  dr fauci increase the power  [Music]  this is pretty upsetting actually that  they have done damage to these those are  17 18 19 year old kids damaged to the  point they would be out there marching  for mandates okay  so why are we doing this what sort of  crazy things are they going to be voting  for what sort of crazy policies because  of what the world did to them